jean zermatten a été définitivement ont
suspendu du réseau social twitter en
raison d'infractions nombreuses et
répétées auraient coûté ce qu'ils nous
ont dit on aura les responsables de
twitter dans un instant la décision est
irrévocable puisque comme l'informé un
mail le compte de monsieur jean messia
ne sera en aucun cas les stories le
conte aurait été suspendu car ni sciages
on aurait été le propriétaire de
plusieurs comptes de plusieurs comptes
aussi ce qui est interdit par exem ple à
ça c'est faux c'est faux c'est faute
d'accord mais je le savais je suis pas
les y aider un certain nombre de comptes
de soutien que je ne dors je ne connais
pas les gestionnaires d'un mois d'accord
alors il ya beaucoup de tweets qui ont
posé problème on va les revoir et vous
allez nous dire si vous comprenez la
décision de twitter ou pas jean je sais
que vous êtes très peiné par cette
affaire oui je suis très peiné parce que
atteindre presque 165 mille abonnés ce
qui était mon cas
quarante mille tweets
presque dix années de présence sur le
réseau c'est un gros travail un gros
investissement
c'est la construction d'une image la
construction d'une base de données la
consule de la construction d'une base
d'abonnés alors évidemment tous les
abonnés ne partagent pas nécessairement
ce que je dis je le leur je vais je
bloque jamais que personne au quasiment
sauf en cas d' insulte est donc rayé
tout cet investissement tout ce travail
d'un trait d'un trait de plume
il y avait une mouche et là il y avait
une attaque
je vous jure qu'il
met enfin en moi la mouche elle est
visible parce que là la raison avancée
par twitter pour moi pour me radier
[Applaudissements]
oui et que d'un côté les pays dont les
élites ont collaboré avec l'allemagne
nazie sont curieusement les pays où les
élites sont fanatiquement attachés à
l'euro très très difficile de se faire
livrer un repas sur rue berri des livres
ou alors la lassitude et une forte
majorité des
personnes pour livrer mais chut
islamisation de la france est un
fantasme et d'extrême droite il est
compliqué cela voilà le terroriste de
nice était pas fichier est glaçant quand
on sait que cinq mines aux musulmans de
jamais celui là celui là saidane via
della six ou sept ans oui mais d'accord
mais il a cédé recul nation il a été
supprimé non mais d'accord mais je veux
dire un moment les mecs ils se disent
nommé est bien noir qui réunit dix ans a
construit un truc dire qu'il en est oui
mais attends je suis désolé
toi demain tu te fais virer de cette
émission d'accord tu vas être convoqué
pour s'expliquer devant quelqu'un qui va
te dire voilà ce que je te reproche
or le problème de twitter c'est qu'on
vous rei
je viens d'investir
année ça n'est pas vrai j'ai pas sinon
j'ai le concept est fermé sept jours
d'audience et finir mais senna tente
d'abord sur quelle base on me dit que
j'accuse la haine mais si ge at ease la
haine pourquoi je ne je n'ai pas été
poursuivi sur ce chef d'accusation par
personne vous rendez compte que sur 165
mille abonnés vous avez des dizaines
d'associations qui ce qui se ferait un
plaisir de se faire un mec comme moi
c'est jamais je dépasse les limites or
ça n'est jamais le cas donc je crois que
la liberté d'expression en france c'est
quand même la loi qui en décide on peut
pas d'un côté dire les réseaux sociaux
font partie de notre vie structure la
vie démocratique structure le débat
politique et d'un autre côté et bien
faire en sorte que ces réseaux sociaux
soient régis comme une entreprise qui
décide de qui doit par les eaux qui ne
doit pas parler alors oui boyard tu
penses que moi gérons longtemps parce
que moi je traîne sur twitter et quand
il a fermé j'ai fait la fête
je viens et après ça c'est moi qui
attisent la haine bah non je vous
déteste pas à tester vos tweets à ce
propos tim non parce que la liberté
d'expression la démocratie c'est quelque
chose de très important mais dans la
démocratie le respect ça existe aussi et
les personnes qui se connectent twitter
et qui voit aux cinq millions de
musulmans qui devrait afficher est au
tout ces livreurs qui sont musulmans ça
en fait chacun de vos tweets fâchez pas
sur twitter les gens postent des photos
de leurs plats ou quelque chose ou
poster une photo de votre avis
le problème c'est que plutôt ce que vous
comprenez pas c'est que twitter ne vous
a pas censurer parce que vous êtes un
anti système c'est twitter s'en fiche de
sa fenêtre est censuré parce que chaque
fois que vous souhaitiez c'était pour
dire une connerie une connerie qui
blessé des gens tel est
ce qui me soutiennent mais ce qui me
saoule le plus c'est d'oser dire que
vous seriez censuré alors que ses 160
c'est tout le tout les followers mais
vous savez vous savez les a vus parce
que vous êtes capable de faire un cas
merci vous savez vous savez juste une
personne qui respectueux ce qui a été
banni parce qu'elle respecte pas
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire donc ça veut dire en fait
que le lot respecte qui sait qui on
décide en fait qui c'est qui défie
twitter
c'est exactement maintenant c'est
exactement comme comme d'une chaîne de
télé une chaîne de télé c'est une
entreprise privée ou presque une chaîne
de télé peut dire je peux je vais
recevoir que des gens de gauche estime
alors j'ai pas je parle pas de gens qui
réflète mais je pas de gens qui sont
politiquement incorrect c'est que la loi
qui peut faire mais veut faire fermer la
gueule à quelqu'un mais c'est pas une
entreprise privée si le twitter twitter
c'est privé ok twitter ça appartient à
twitter ils peuvent encore décidé et
twitter il ya des angoisses aux eyzies
toute
la sexualité le harcèlement et que ça
parmi lesquels voilà l'incitation à la
haine yadir accords annoncés les règles
parmi les règles si vous voulez le voir
comme un ruisseau à l'encan alors parlez
vous
parlons-en de l'incitation à la haine
quid d'un certain nick conrad dans sa
chanson ni clément un mec qui a été
condamné pour incitation à la haine par
le tribunal et qui fait encore jusqu'à
aujourd'hui la promotion de cette
chanson sur twitter elle a jamais alors
rien parce qu'il n'est pas aussi est ce
que vous seriez pas de sortir est ce que
vous savez que le porte parole des
talibans le bien nommé à berlin zouhair
d'accord il a encore bien long mais il a
encore son compte twitter est diffusée
sur le kali peu sur lequel il peut
propager c'est juste étudions le cabinet
non mais c'est pas ça c'est que attendez
je suis un con plus longue si ces gens
là si c'est jouer parce que amir al
assad allait l'égorger de dieu ou sa
faîtière de dieu donc c'est quand même
l'un des alpes à l'allemand et d'autre
m
le fait que le contenu le compte du ccf
d'accord le ccf qui a été dissous en
france par darmana parce qu'ils avaient
participé indirectement on doit
contribuer au contest qui a amené à la
décapitation de samuel pâtit il s'est
tranquillement reconstitué en belgique
et le président du ccf qui est
directement impliqué dans cette
dissolution a encore son congrès c'est
ça votre défense patrice
evra ça sert à aider les gens dont je
parle ont été condamnés par la justice